how do we balance content creation and
university studies Sophie asks so I
think when it comes to balancing YouTube
content creation and anything whether
it's University studies a 40-hour week
job with a 1 hour or 2hour commute I
think the first step is to do a Time
audit the second step is to identify any
things you can cut out of your calendar
okay I identified 5 hours a week I
identifi 10 hours a week I would then
number three write down
your values and your priorities I will
admit Sophie that it could be possible
that it's not a season that you can
really do YouTube but you might
literally say you're like Sean I'm
taking 18 credits I also am already a
parent and I have six kids I also work
two
jobs and how do I do YouTube as well and
I would tell you uh you don't so like
sometimes I think we could be
impractical with our schedule on the
flip side once we start finding what's
on our schedule we backfill that's what
I would say values and priorities so
when you know what your values and
priorities are in list you're like okay
number one I can't let my university
studies drop but then is your priority
gaming or watching Netflix or something
else and if you've got something like
YouTube aide hustle then that's what's
going to get plugged in to that 10-hour
Gap that you freed up and then you guard
that thing diligently and you're like
what I can't do I'm going to nurture a
couple friendships but I'm just not
going to go out fr night ET I'm going to
sleep recover and I'm going to crush my
side hustle on Saturday while everybody
else is partying I'm going to be
building my future and focusing on my
purpose and my priorities and then
here's your radical tip I'm not
suggesting this just throwing it out
there this isn't directed to Sophie it's
directed to everybody what if you just
drop out of
University I mean I'm not suggesting
that that's the move at least for the
thought
exercise worth questioning
the whole thing not being irrational and
crazy but someone's like well Sean I'm
just in an area where I can't grow my
YouTube channel because I'm in a small
town and I'm not like where all the
action is well the cool thing about
YouTube is you don't need to you can do
it from anywhere but here's the radical
thought move well my current job and my
current boss like they're just holding
me back and like I just then quit well
like I mean I just don't think I could
do YouTube because I mean if I look at
all the priorities and all the things
that I'm doing on my schedule and I've
got I hang out with my my friend Leisa
every week and we do this kind of thing
and then I hang out with Rebecca well do
you really even like Lisa and Rebecca
think about it I want to invite you guys
to our YouTube 1K challenge you can join
this challenge for free as we show you
how to grow your first 1,000 subscribers
and make your first $1,000 on YouTube
we've had countless people join us
during this 1K challenge who are now at
1,000 subscribers and past 1,000
subscribers making money money on
YouTube and you could be the next person
if you just go to 21k challenge.com you
can sign up for the very next challenge
and we can't wait to see you guys there
because if you're really auditing are
you is your calendar aligned with your
highest values with your future why are
you going to University are you going to
University because it's related to the
career that for sure you're going to do
and that's the stability are you going
because your parents told you to go and
you're are you going because you just
like hate not finishing things so you're
going to finish it and rack up more debt
I'm not trying to get into your business
Sophie I'm trying to talk to all of us
to just say sometimes it's smart to
question how could I look at this from a
whole different Vantage Point could I
reduce my monthly what do you spend
audit final tip audit your calendar and
audit your credit card I was just
talking to my friend Benji about this I
said man you want to know what
somebody's values are you don't have to
talk to them if you could if you could
look at two things look at their
calendar for the last 90 days and look
at their credit card or your debit card
for you Dave Ramsey fans and look at
where did your money go and where did
your time go and if we look at your
credit card and we're like okay so it
went to a drake ticket Taylor Swift
ticket it went to a Mariners game it
went to hundreds of dollars on alcohol
and uh hot dogs out of Mariners game it
went to all this you know whatever it
went to golf it went to some other
things and then my calendar went to this
job that I don't really like but I just
tolerate it because I just don't want to
and then we edit the whole thing and you
go Sean I just don't have time for my
dreams well if you reduced spending on
the Drake tickets the Taylor Swift
tickets the the overpriced beer at the
sports game and the other things that
would allow you to maybe go part-time at
your job or get a different job thereby
buying you some time back thereby
allowing you to work on your side hustle
for a little bit longer but that's
entirely up to you because what are your
values what are your priorities and
don't it's not what you tell me your
values and priorities are it's it's what
your calendar tells me your values and
priorities are because that's actually
how you're spending your time and it's
what your checkbook tells me well Sean I
always got to get a new outfit and I
always got to order Uber Eats and I
always have to get my coffee and I
always have to and I'm a big
encouragement of that stuff I'm never
like the path to become a millionaire is
not going to Starbucks that's like
actually not what I believe but I think
the path to becoming a millionaire is
making more money and investing it
smarter and producing more not really
thinking about constriction but thinking
about abundance and thinking about
expansion but you know drink your coffee
so you can come home and edit for longer
you know I think like how do I get
entrepreneurial while enjoying my Uber
Eats and my coffee however it is smart
in some Seasons to be like dear God I
could literally recover ,000 dollar a
month because I'm being so I'm such a
poor Steward of my financial resources
and in doing so I would actually be able
to now reach faster towards my YouTube
dreams you could take a radical move
drop out quit move
relocate drop the energy vampire friends
drop the time you think you have to
go I'm not trying to disrupt your
business but you go and playing golf for
four five six hours not only the expense
but the guys that you're hanging out
with and I don't know if iron really
sharpened iron there but by the time it
was all gossip by the time it was all
about like just complaining about your
spouse by the time it was guys just
complaining about their job and not
Mastermind and brainstorming about how
to be creative and industrious and how
to be positive and how to take territory
and how to move things man just staying
home saving money and working on your
side hustle or on some personal
development Compound Effect multiplied
by 3 69 12 months five years 10 years
puts you in a whole different place by
making that radical shift to your
checkbook or to your calendar if you
enjoyed this content and want to take
your YouTube channel to the next level
just click or tap the link on the screen
or go to two 1K challenge.com to join
our next live YouTube challenge you'll
learn our best tips and strategies that
are working here at think media and I
think you'll love it